el grupo Wagner no tiene registro legal
en ninguna parte del mundo Cómo afecta
ese vacío jurídico las posibilidades de
frenar la colaboración de gobiernos y
privados con esa organización
ese es el problema que es una
organización que oficialmente
en vista de que la ley rusa prohíbe los
grupos vamos a decirlo privado militares
o mercenarios Pues es lo que es
realmente y su líder vamos a decir
político
es amigo de Putin es uno de sus hombres
de confianza y mittributkin teniente
coronel de la inteligencia militar rusa
pues eh este lo atribuye se le atribuye
la fundación vamos a decir operativa de
ese grupo también otro miembro vamos a
decir de confianza del círculo vamos a
decir de Putin Así que cuando ellos pues
han estado combatiendo en Siria
República centroafricana Mali por
ejemplo o en el paz en 2014 y tras la
invasión del 2022 en Ucrania Pues claro
oficialmente
hay un algo nebuloso no el gobierno ruso
Pues los considera Putin como parte de
las fuerzas pero al mismo tiempo es como
que si no lo fueran oficialmente pero
realmente lo son porque están vinculados
en mi opinión a la inteligencia militar
rusa del Estado Mayor de las fuerzas
armadas rusas Bueno brevemente le
pregunto se tiene registro de los
activos reales y movimientos financieros
del grupo que obtiene su financiamiento
Pues en gran medida de este tráfico de
recursos naturales de los países donde
actúa
bueno esas cifras no las tengo pero como
suele ocurrir con grupos de inteligencia
apoyados por el gobierno ruso digamos
que las ramificaciones han de ser
variadas y profundas estoy pesado por
ejemplo en otro caso el de Víctor que
fue canjeado ya saben que fue de la
inteligencia militar rusa y era pues
Traficante de armas pero lo hacía no a
nivel personal en mi opinión sino por
órdenes probablemente directas de
Vladimir Putin o de la inteligencia
militar rusa Entonces por ejemplo para
que tenga una idea
frigoyen es El Financiero El Financiero
del grupo Este pero el grupo este Warner
se fundó por otro grupo que pues
se abrió otro grupo llamado el cuerpo de
ejército eslabonico que participó en
2014 en el bondon y después en Siria y
ese grupo eslabón y con cuerpo de
ejército eslabonico que es el predecesor
de que estaba basado en Hong Kong O sea
que el y recibe armas al parecer el
grupo Wagner de Corea del Norte no me
sorprendería que drones de esos kamikaze
iraníes también se han operado por este
grupo O sea que realmente es difícil
apreciar el la cantidad de dinero que
tengan pero lo último 50.000 hombres se
le atribuye que tienen de los cuales en
el 40.000 son convictos Diez mil son los
del núcleo duro de Los profesionales
pero usan por ejemplo el té guión 90m
que es lo más moderno el tanque de
combate más moderno que tiene el
ejército ruso O sea que tienen un trato
especial aunque se quejen que le falta
municiones y viene a ver en la primavera
que este año una nueva ofensiva rusa que
te está hablando ellos van a recibir
trato preferente mi opinión en cuanto al
equipo para servir punta de cuña en
avanzar en esa nueva ofensiva